[Music]
and war ravage the earth the gods
created us
I will fight for those who cannot fight
for themselves
Wonder Woman was rated pg-13 experienced
at an IMAX 3d who's this young woman
she's my she and I are
working together sir
Dyanne princess of Timnath Prince Diana
Prince rated pg-13 experienced at an
IMAX 3d the gods gave us many gifts one
day you'll know them all this is where
we keep them it's beautiful
who would wield it only the fiercest
among us even could and that is not you
Diana
you will train her harder than any
Amazon before her five times harder ten
times harder never let your guard down
you expect the battles will be fair
until she is better than even you but
she must never know the truth about what
she is
[Music]
[Applause]
what is this place who are you
it is our sacred duty to defend the
world hey where were you are you are in
more danger than you think
be careful Diana no one else will defend
the world than I must welcome to jolly
old London be here yeah it's not for
everybody
or maybe not
is there anything else you want to show
me
[Music]
[Music]
what
I am day I know them Akira daughter of
Hippolyta in the name of all that is
good feel wrath upon this world is over
[Music]
um yep that's not gonna work please put
the sword down it doesn't go with the
outfit at all
but the closer you get the more you see
the great darkness within